le sud liban une nouvelle fois ce et à
sang depuis hier avec des affrontements
cette fois entre palestiniens le fatah
de yasser arafat essaye de déloger les
révolutionnaires de rbo nidal de leurs
positions à saïda premier bilan après le
24 heures d'affrontements 49
commentaires de m croisé au cuit de
rendez-vous humour et les membres du
fatah pour ça sans merci les derniers
partisans d'abou nidal méthodiquement
les combattants de yasser arafat raki
toutes les rues du camp des lits loués
aux parents des principaux daft matant
les poches de résistance d'abidal et
dont les combats de rue au mortier lits
meubles et immeubles ou au tir à bout
portant
49 personnes ont trouvé la mort quand
110 blessés frères d'hier ennemis
d'aujourd'hui abou nidal a quitté la
fraction majoritaire de l'ol paie en
1973 pour qu'on ait le fatah le conseil
révolutionnaire était lente et dans de
nombreuses actions terroristes peut être
le rapt d'occidentaux
le fatah est décidé à en finir avec abou
nidal car selon lui était d'actions
terroristes nuisent au peuple
palestinien
il semble que yasser arafat cherche à
éliminer les branches extremis de la
centrale
comme pour rester ouverts à l'extérieur
à toute possibilité de dialogue de
négociations au proche-orient duels
d'artillerie viennent de reprendre ce
soir le coeur de la ville de saïda a été
bombardée depuis la première fois depuis
le déclenchement de ces combats
interpalestiniens nouveau bilan fait
état de 53 morts et 277 blessés